this is fry beau I have seen the salty
starchy heart of darkness and it is fry
beau I never thought the death of the
potato product could be so brutal
oh no I really find that was Wow uh it
was really funny though um that was like
something out of a horror uh this is an
episode where Steve is looking for his
pants cuz he's a mess Steven Oh haven't
we all been there pantsless up at the
same time for them you um but uh yes I'm
blind so he's trying to find his pants
and pearl tells in that there's this
missing shard of a jewel and he loses
focus and doesn't realize that the jewel
brings close to life so he's thinking
about his pants yes and apparently and
pants are thinking about him apparently
they're now alive apparently is the
substitutionary locomotion jewel yeah at
the end especially electric orgy you
don't know what that is watch Bedknobs
and Broomsticks classic see an older
movie stupor Millennials um so yeah so
he goes and uh you know it tries to use
it for good he comes across this boy who
has to be in this fry bow costume and
Steven suggests they put the jewel in a
row first he tries it like you know
playing up the joke in then that doesn't
work so he tries the jewel if I don't
know at first seems great but then
anything like that they basically
summoned fried food yeah is whatever
there is like french fries like
tentacles like fries at the people's
mouths are fucking fries and the kid
realizes that while they tried to go at
v-- kids as he puts it let's begin uh
his childhood might slowly be
disappearing it was my favorite moment
where he keeps popping up like in each
time the face changes it
uh so yeah he realizes that the job
stated my job don't understand someday
Steven when you have a real job but I do
a real job I save humanity um and but
then fry Bo goes crazy and the father
apologized maybe be in the suit too long
even though he technically wasn't in the
suit and he probably should punish him
but babe a bonds demon instead decides
to use his clothes against fry Bo and
what ensues is one of the most gruesome
battles and what's even coming at you
smells great yellow stuff you just know
like hurl the hand in hey you see I was
just mesmerized by I'm like wow this if
you if you chum this in a cartoon
happening to a person like you'd be put
in prison like there would be some FCC
violation you'd be locked in jail throw
away the key well that's why I came
short circuit to house like your bells
Ted to a person would be like you guys
and yummy you gotta feel like borderline
nc-17 not a county memo I know if you
shove this Avenue human this would be a
fuckin nc-17 them I mean basically pearl
takes a spear stamps the thing in the
item all of this ketchup yeah hey mister
good lion she shed blood let's just say
no it's not blood it's just ketchup like
that that would make all of this ketchup
comes gushing out completely soaks pearl
then yeah the Steven goes to town with
all the pants beating the shit out of
the thing like the big tips over the
brown then Steven like reaches into its
mother pulls out like the the gem that's
keeping it alive and then the thing
finally mercifully died its I'm like
holy shit that was like worse a Temple
of Doom I guess okay cuz they give him a
Viking funeral which was pretty funny
that made me laugh cuz I'm like oh
please if they're putting him on a boat
please set it on fire what he whipped
out the little lighter I'm like yes um
so I appreciated the wanted violence I'm
like wow yeah on top at the animation
this one like was especially good but in
the expressions just seem really good
they seem like borderline ren and stimpy
and how like really enjoyably like very
exaggerated but they feel like they're
still kind of physical they don't feel
flat they feel like there's dimension to
them even though the smiles are getting
really baby can see sort of the stretch
lines with them and stuff
III thought cat hands cat fingers are
bad i-i-i have a name for my pain and it
is frybo
well even that fry by the weights design
you know your big smile like the Stay
Puft Marshmallow smile it's so soulless
it's like happy but soulless at the same
time it's like one of your smiles um
yeah just like that
so imagine that coming at you as I'm
sure there's some fanfic right I'd like
to imagine that coming out of it I would
have loved to I always joke that my
smile was the basis for the Burger King
mask of a Burger King King oh just the
smile um oh yeah so terrified absolutely
terrified it was very funny though um
the hoggar the horror that there's a lot
of things I could identify with
particularly the losing the focus in the
opening cuz that's having to be quite a
bit like somebody's talking em I might
of water be like shit whoa well that
presents a shit he's still talking up um
just nod yeah you know what if I don't
remember I'll just say I blanked out cuz
I actually have no problem most
conventions if you're talking to Doug
about anything always thinking of his
where are my pants if you see me and I'm
sitting down at a table my pants are not
on so yeah don't we zoom in the next
convention fry yet that one's gonna see
how pantsless I really go apparently
that's not a thing there anyways the
song is um can we get back to fully
clothed no fucking Anzhi pantsless
that's really more important let's not
say we did
oh no the animation was very good the I
like this kid that they introduced the
one that feels like you know is
childhood asleep I like that the hair
looks like french fries yes touch I like
that too um I little touches that they
say I don't know why I said unwanted by
me and are all over Philly
it stays Stephen himself just for this
little Gabi seasick he's friggin
adorable I just love always looking
through it just goes you know you are a
mess Steven I'm like that is so precious
um I think the UH is one of few ones
where you only see one of the one in
just gems or one of the women now
Christmas crystal gems is over the hot
gem chicks okay Jim is Molly you think
that was always the joke that they're
called Jim except it's spelled properly
I don't know I never thought about that
uh can I have a gem feel I'm mostly in
the dark about this show so I don't know
much about the creation of it oh but no
I like it because it sort of had like a
little bit of like it had the extreme
action at the end a head kind of a goofy
nose this is the most this little boring
around Emma sewed so far this set we
yeah um the previous two were good but
this I like this one alive just yeah fun
it was yeah it just it felt like you
would put is callaghan action-packed
spongebob episode it kind of that random
humor to it too edgy
it felt more like an adventure time
episode the more I think about it uh you
know I had a lot of good last but it
also had spent easier it go with that
don't bring in the sponge the hate does
fun fun games and I can't I got shocked
by this it's like it's it's a fucking
spy he's called Spongebob Squarepants
how do you hate something called
spongebob square beta man hate I'm just
indifferent to it but apparently there's
like a whole like this die hard as an
agent of know there's this Legion of
people who sincerely believe as part of
their religion if you will that
spongebob was once a great and worthy
show and that somehow the sponge has
lost his way and jumps the shark
I guess as it were in the ocean some
heads up multiple she's is there people
is like now you know get it f to season
three the show went to shit and like
then then there's a but no but the movie
brought it back without the Golden Age
of sponge
I'm a pastor going down i i i don't know
i i've never been a fan I don't I hate
it more for the attention he gets more
than I hate the show it so it is
overplay it's kinda like the frozen of
Nickelodeon it is totally the frozen of
Nickelodeon it's more just cuz like I
can't go flipping through stations
without finding it on somewhere and I'm
like Jesus Christ is it running 24/7
like does Nickelodeon own 12 networks
and sponge my hips to be running at the
same time is somewhere late but yeah
otherwise I don't care about spongebob
but hey we got sidetracked again this
show is not or was that your argument
that this show is sponge worthy well
played like three tentative Seinfeld
look it up I don't know it I don't know
sponge worthy is a good thing or a bad
thing in this case um but I mean to
interview it time I like about a
spongebob but ya know the Elias it's the
animation this one particularly stood
out to me as uh just really funny and
even when they're having the more
honesty like that to you were talking
about with the kids head keeps popping
up in the frame uh you know etc that's
also read and awkward yeah that's both
really funny and really sad at the same
time and I like it when episode can can
combine that comedy with whoa whoa we
called it sad word soft word awkward
I think this awkward decision so um yeah
so yeah no good episode uh really funny
Alex especially good animation really
sponge with yes and brutal very brutal
uh at so much violence so much yummy
delicious starchy salty greasy violence
there's probably like you know a family
of fry guys watching no one french fries
are they going to run out of food I
don't know we're gonna get yo we're
gonna get in trouble if they start
upping like the price quotient like
necks it's gonna be fighting sushi like
shit that's gonna get expenses if
someone ever made like a Steven universe
restaurant like you would never run out
of menu options you would just always
hello I would get something
I can't oh my god so nice sweet let's
order the together breakfast and then
the fry bowl plate and now the cat
fingers wait it made for real cats they
are well you better get those oh um so
yeah good episode I will see you the
next one